just a warning that this report by our
U.S correspondent James Matthews shows a
video of The Assault on Tyree before his
death which some may find distressing
prosecutors say this is a man's murder
and this is how it started
Tyree Nichols is the man being arrested
the only man seemingly trying to cam the
situation
man if you don't lay down
stop I'm not doing it
Tyree breaks free from police who've
deployed pepper spray and a taser
[Applause]
a short distance away they catch him
again he's wrestled to the ground
again
a CCTV camera on a street Lamppost
captures the continuing assault with
Fists
and with feet
Tyree by this time struggling to speak
sounds like he's trying to comply
one officer positions himself to strike
with his extender baton
this is taking place close to tyree's
home
in the midst of the assault he calls out
for his mum
he calls to his mother three times
they're the last words
Tyree and handcuffs and Billy conscious
is prompt against a vehicle
there are fist bumps between the
officers who've assaulted him one
complains he's injured his leg my leg
by the car Tyree slumps sideways onto
the ground
his condition is clearly deteriorating
others arrived with what looks like
medical kit but they stand and watch
Tyree he's dying but they offer no help
for more than 20 minutes
Tyree is told simply he can't go
anywhere
and ambulance eventually arrives but
Tyree will die in hospital
in reaction to the video in Memphis
there wasn't a violent protest this city
had feared but there were Street
demonstrations
it's just heartbreaking to say the least
it made me serious just upset just
seeing it only manifested what we
already thought and the sickening it
definitely hurt me and I'm gonna think
about it probably for the rest of my
life now so
the authorities in Memphis were
concerned that the prospect of violent
protests there seems little doubt that
the timing of the charges against the
officers and the seriousness of them has
gone some distance to defusing public
anger
foreign
the five police officers charged with
second-degree murder have for now been
released on bail
their actions have fueled fresh debates
around U.S policing and its problems
though no words speak louder than the
pictures
James Matthews Sky News in Memphis